So when I was born on September 26, 1988,
my grandparents and great
grandparents back in India
didn't find out for two weeks,
which is a shame because I mean,
look how perfect I was.
(Laughter)
And it's not because the phone
lines were down
or because they weren't available.
It's because there was
a complication with my birth.
And that complication
was being assigned female at birth.
You see, because my mom had been told
that if she gave birth to a daughter,
it wasn't worth phoning home about.
After all, she’d already given birth
to my older sister,
and this time everyone had high hopes
that she would do right and have a son.
But she didn't.
She had me.
And so there were no congratulations
or Indian sweets sent our way.
Just the reality that from the moment
I came into this world,
I was already a disappointment
to so many people.
It's as if they had a time machine
and already knew the trajectory
of my entire career and life
and decided that I had less to offer.
And it sucked.
So why am I telling you this heavy story?
I'm supposed to be a funny person.
I have the nerve to come out here
and hit you right in the feels.
How dare I?
I'm telling you this because although
this is my lived experience,
it's also the reality
that millions of girls face every day
across every culture and in every country.
And I'm telling you this
because being born into this reality
set me on a lifetime mission
of trying to prove myself
and just feel like I was enough.
What did I want to be when I grow up?
I wanted to be treated equally.
And I'm not alone in this mission.
In fact, us girls,
what we desperately want
is a seat at the table.
It's what every motivational poster,
Tumblr post, Instagram account you follow,
business card tells us:
Success is a seat at the table.
And if they want to be extra spicy,
they say, "If there is no seat,
drag your own seat."
I'm sure you've heard this, right?
And so my marching orders were clear.
Get a seat at this coveted table
by any means necessary.
And that's been the driving force
behind my entire career.
Now, in 2010,
I noticed that no one
on YouTube looked like me.
There was no South Asian woman
who's very loud and uses her hands a lot,
giving her take on the world.
There was no me in front of a camera.
I saw a seat up for grabs.
So I got to work, and I started a channel
under the name “Superwoman.”
Yeah, because although
I’m smart enough to do a TED Talk,
I'm not smart enough
to understand copyright.
(Laughter)
I taught myself how to write,
shoot and edit my own content.
And I worked really hard.
When I finally got the hang of it,
I committed to posting
two comedy videos a week.
And I found success.
With a backwards snapback on my head,
I gave my take on relationships,
pop culture, taboo subjects
and, most popularly,
dressed up like my parents.
(Laughter)
I can't tell you how many times
I forgot to wipe that chest hair off.
A lot of times.
(Laughter)
Now fast forward to 2015,
and I'm on stage in India
announcing my first world tour.
As fate would have it,
the day after this monumental milestone,
I was set to fly to Punjab, India
to visit my grandfather
for the first time in my adult life.
And whoo, nothing could have prepared me
for what was about to happen.
I vividly remember it.
I was in the car driving to his house.
He was standing outside.
I nervously got out of the car,
walked up to him.
He walked up to me,
looked me right in the eyes,
and he raised his hand
and decorated me with a flower garland:
a gesture fit for people of importance.
He then proceeded to welcome me
into his home, my mom by my side,
and proceed to show me
all the newspaper clippings he had saved
with my name and face on them.
He said the words he was wrong.
Words I had never heard
a man say before to me.
He said that I had done
what no one else could have done,
and I had made the family name proud.
Me, Lilly, the baby born a girl.
That's right.
Now in that moment
I truly felt like Superwoman.
I did.
You know, through my YouTube videos,
I've amassed almost 15 million subscribers
and three billion views.
But more important than all of that,
I managed to change one view.
I challenged my grandfather's
entrenched gender beliefs.
And for the first time in my life,
I remember thinking in that moment,
“Oh, I finally got
a seat at the table ...”
Hello, props.
(Laughter)
" ... alongside the men in the industry.”
I felt like that.
And encouraged
by my grandfather's approval,
I became more confident in my influence.
I remember thinking, "Oh, I'm going
to talk at this table,
I'm going to join
the dinner conversation."
You know, a lot of my male mentors
make comments and posts
about box office numbers
and salaries and titles
and those dollar dollar bills.
So I thought,
I'm going to chime in here.
I learned very quickly
that whenever I spoke of money,
people got a little uncomfortable.
Like the time I pointed out the gender gap
in the Forbes list for online creators,
a list I'd previously been on.
I remember wanting to start
a critical conversation
because I saw this article
and I was heartbroken.
You know, the digital space
had always been a place
that I thought was without gatekeepers.
And here it was looking
just like old Hollywood.
Well, let me tell you,
the internet was not interested.
I don't know how it's possible,
but it literally felt as if Twitter
leaped through my screen
and body slammed me onto my desk.
The message was clear:
you can be on this list,
but don't try to start any conversations
about the inequality on this list.
I have thousands and thousands of videos.
One of my most disliked videos
is why I’m not in a relationship.
Yeah.
A lot of the men at the table
did not like me telling them
why I didn't need a boyfriend.
I quickly learned
that there’s an invisible
gatekeeper called culture,
and the table is smack dab
in the middle of it.
Now, in 2019,
I made history with my late-night show,
“A Little Late with Lilly Singh.”
Thank you, thank you.
(Applause)
There I was, Lilly,
the baby born a brown girl,
rubbing elbows, or at least time slots,
with comedy royalty.
And I got to give a huge shout out to NBC
for boldly trying to break
late-night tradition.
I remember when the show came out,
I remember all the articles
because they looked practically identical.
"Bisexual Woman of Color
Gets Late-Night Show."
I almost legally changed my name
to "bisexual woman of color"
because that's what people
called me so often.
And you know, as strange
as that sentiment was, I thought, OK,
the silver lining is that we'll finally
get a different perspective in late-night.
A little bit of melanin, a dash of queer,
a different take on things.
Let's do this!
And I remember thinking,
"Now, oh, now I've been invited
to the big table.
And now things will be different."
So I took my seat.
Now, unfortunately,
the budget wasn't based
on the importance or significance
or historic nature of the show.
It was based on the 1:30am
time-slot that we had.
So to say the budget was small,
the writing staff even smaller,
and to do the first season,
I had to shoot 96 episodes
of late-night television in three months.
Audience: Whoo.
LS: Whoo is right.
To put that into perspective,
that is shooting two
to three episodes a day
versus the network standard of one a day,
maybe two on Thursday.
We did it all with a writing staff
of about half a dozen writers
versus the network standard
that's about double that.
Words cannot explain
to you how exhausting,
emotionally and spiritually
challenging that was.
And I started to feel like,
"Hm, I think this chair's
a little wobbly."
Now, I think we can all agree
that the beauty and magic
of late-night is its timeliness.
You know that no matter
what's happening in the world,
you can turn on late-night television
and hear all about it.
But when you shoot 96 episodes
in three months,
you kind of lose that magic.
I was the only show talking about
hooking up, partying, cuddling, traveling,
in front of a live audience
during a literal global pandemic.
Now, still, I thought,
if the budget doesn't celebrate
the historicness of the show,
then the creative can.
I can bring some much needed
spice to late-night.
And sometimes I was successful.
But other times,
I would receive notes like,
"Don't be so loud."
"Don't be so big."
"Don't be so angry, smile more."
And my all time favorite,
"Don't overindex
on the South Asian stuff."
After all, everyone else at the table
who's been sitting there for years,
people are used to them.
I might be a little jarring to audiences.
Now, during season two of my show,
I remember I went into overdrive.
I found all the loopholes,
I did all the necessary jobs
to try to make the show more timely.
And I was excited to.
And I felt compelled to
because for the first time in history,
we had a woman, not to mention
half South Asian woman,
become vice president
of the United States.
Now we witnessed one of the greatest
protests in human history
with the farmer protests in India.
And I was excited to finally give
my take on these things.
But my take was almost never included
in topical media news coverage round-ups.
You know, we still got the same voices,
the same perspectives,
even though someone
and something different
was literally in the next time slot.
I kept trying to pull up my seat.
I kept trying to join
the dinner conversation.
I kept trying to ask
for a more supportive seat.
But every time I would be told
that I should be grateful
to have a seat in the first place.
After all, everyone else
that looks like me
is still waiting outside
the restaurant in the cold.
You know, the strange thing
about having a wobbly seat
is that you spend so much time
trying to keep it upright
that you can never bring
your full self to the table.
So now, why am I telling you all this?
Well, because my therapist
costs 200 dollars an hour
and this is way cheaper.
(Laughter)
But also because I just experienced
one of the most notorious boys' clubs ever
in late-night television.
And I'm here to offer solutions.
I don't always follow up
a venting session with solutions,
but when I do, it’s a TED Talk.
(Laughter)
That's right.
(Applause)
You see, my goal was always
a seat at the table.
It's what women are conditioned
to believe success is.
And when the chair doesn't fit,
when it doesn't reach the table,
when it's wobbly,
when it's full of splinters,
we don't have the luxury
of fixing it or finding another one.
But we try anyways.
We take on that responsibility,
and we shoulder that burden.
Now, I've been fortunate enough
to sit at a few seats,
at a few different tables.
And what I've learned is,
when you get the seat,
trying to fix the seat
won't fix the problem.
Why?
Because the table was never built
for us in the first place.
The solution?
Build better tables.
(Applause)
So, allow me to be
your very own IKEA manual.
I would like to present to you
a set of guidelines
I very eloquently call:
“How to Build a Table that Doesn’t Suck”.
(Laughter)
I've been told I'm very literal.
Now, right off the bat, let me tell you,
this assembly is going to take
more than one person
or group of people.
It's going to take everyone.
Are you ready? Should we dive in?
Let's do it.
Up first,
don't weaponize gratitude.
Now, don't get me wrong,
gratitude is a great word.
It's nice, it's fluffy,
a solid 11 points in Scrabble.
However, let's be clear.
Although gratitude feels warm and fuzzy,
it's not a form of currency.
Women are assigned 10 percent more work
and spend more time on unrewarded,
unrecognized and non-promotable tasks.
Basically, what this means is
all the things men don't want to do
are being handed to women,
and a lot of those things largely include
things that advance inclusivity,
equity and diversity in the workplace.
So hear me when I say,
a woman shouldn't be grateful
to sit at a table.
She should be paid to sit at a table.
(Applause)
Especially ones she largely helped build.
And a woman's seat shouldn't be threatened
if she doesn't seem "grateful" enough.
In other words, corporations,
this step involves a woman doing a job
and being paid in money,
opportunity and promotion,
not just gratitude.
And women -- yeah, go ahead,
live it up, live your life.
(Applause)
And women, a moment of real talk,
trust me, I've been there
and I know it's so tough,
but we have to understand
and remember that being grateful
and being treated fairly
are not mutually exclusive.
I can be grateful but still know
exactly what I deserve.
And that's the way to do it.
(Applause)
Up next, invest in potential.
When investing in women,
don’t invest in the 1:30am time slot.
Invest in empowering something different.
Invest in a new voice.
Give them the support they actually need.
Cultural change takes time and money.
Heck, it took my grandfather 25 years
to see that I was worthy of more.
So a true investment is one
that values potential over proof.
Because so often that proof
doesn't exist for women.
Not because we aren't qualified,
but because we haven't been
given the opportunity.
In other words,
if you're trying to be inclusive,
don't give someone new
a seat made of straw
until they prove
they deserve a better one.
Don't hold something
called a "prove it again" bias,
which requires less privileged people
to constantly keep proving themselves,
even though white men tend to get by
on just their potential.
Give them a seat that they can thrive in,
that they can do the job
you hired them to do in.
Allow them to contribute to the table,
and they will make it better.
Up next, this is my favorite one.
My favorite one, it's quite
common sense, actually.
Make space for us.
You know, for every three men at a table,
there's only one
place setting for a woman.
People are so used to more men
showing up that they plan for it.
There's an extra seat in the corner,
there's a steak under the heat lamp.
When more men show up,
the table gets longer.
But when that extra RSVP is a woman,
more often than not
she's encouraged to compete
against the only other woman
that was invited to the table.
Instead, we need to build
multiple seats for multiple women,
not just one or two,
so that women are not sitting
on top of each other's laps,
fighting for one meal.
We already know that more
diverse teams perform better.
A recent study shows
that corporations that have
more gender diversity
on their executive teams,
were 25 percent more likely
to experience above average profitability.
And more racially diverse companies
had 36 percent more profit.
So really, no matter how you look at it,
it's time to build
longer tables and more seats.
And I want to say something,
and I want to admit something,
I want to be vulnerable for a second.
Because I've fallen victim
to this so many times,
and women, let me know
if you've experienced this.
We have to get rid of the scarcity mindset
and champion each other,
you know, because I've learned
what's the better win?
Me sitting at a table
or us sitting at a table?
Don't be convinced to fight for one spot.
Instead fight for multiple spots.
(Applause)
And let me lead by example
right now and say,
I know there’s many other women
that are going to come on this stage,
and I hope they all nail it,
and I will be cheering you all on
because we can all win.
And I'm going to be your biggest
cheerleader when you're up here.
(Applause)
Last, it's time to upgrade the table talk.
Now, I believe stories
make the world go around.
You thought it had something
to do the solar system?
Joke's on you, it's stories.
(Laughs)
Stories are how we understand ourselves,
how we understand others
and how we understand the world.
And arguably the most important stories
are those we see in the media.
Because we’ve seen time and time
that they control the narrative
and impact culture.
Now, when it comes to genre,
you can argue that certain genres
have certain target demographics.
When it comes to the world news,
the target demographic is the world,
and we know half of the world is female.
Yet women and girls make up only
a quarter of the people interviewed
or that the news is even about
in the first place.
Instead, when it comes to issues
that impact women,
we not only need to be included
in the coverage,
we need to be driving those stories
and dimensionalizing our own experience.
Inviting everyone in on the table talk
isn't just a nice gesture.
It makes for better, more productive,
smarter conversation
with more than one point of view.
And that's how you get better.
So this all sounds like a lot of work.
And it is.
But I'm going to tell you
why it's necessary and worth it.
To be honest, this is about so much more
than just women in the workplace.
In fact, I could probably come up
with many more guidelines
across many other industries.
This is about creating a world
where half of the population can thrive.
You see, because the work we do today
can create a world
where future generations of girls
can have equitable access and opportunity.
And here's the best part.
Are you ready for it?
Everyone listening today,
all the men, the women,
everyone in between, the big companies,
the small ones, the media outlets,
the people that snuck
into the back, all of you,
you can help create this future.
A future where we have longer tables
and more seats that actually work
instead of fighting for a seat
at the old ones that don't.
A future where everyone
is seated at the table equally.
And a future
where being assigned female at birth
is not a disappointment
or a disadvantage,
because girls are encouraged,
empowered and expected to do great things.
And I can't wait to make that a reality.
Thank you so much.
(Applause and cheers)